[Music]
with space for 200,000 spectators the
Chinese Grand Prix is a huge Formula One
fixture but large crowds and coronavirus
don't mix and now conformation the
Shanghai race jus in April is off
postponed indefinitely obviously
disappointed but we understand I mean
you know I think we largely expected you
know this to happen you know clearly the
indications and what's been evolving
over the last couple of weeks certainly
led to this being you know probably we
expected a tough decision for both fans
and f1 teams
it's a tragedy that's happening in the
world I mean I would like to go to China
and not have the various and you know
for everyone to be safe and to race like
we like we should but at the moment it
is unsafe for us to go and that's it's
not hard to see why numerous events have
been canceled parts of Shanghai are in
shutdown and the world is watching
China's response to the virus in Japan
the Diamond Princess cruise ship remains
in floating quarantine with increasing
cases on board emergency staff are on
permanent standby it's prompting
questions about this summer's Tokyo
Olympics when we run for London 2012 a
disease like this emerging around the
world was one of the highest risks we
had not because it's likely but because
the consequences can be quite severe in
terms of running the games so the little
thought of through but they will still
be having sleepless nights at the moment
as he goes through the plans again and
it's not just sporting events cooled off
despite earlier assurances Barcelona's
Mobile World Congress the world's
biggest annual technology show isn't
happening the latest but probably not
the last global event to be canceled
Norah bundok sky
News